hello and welcome it's December 10th
2024 we're in active inference art
stream number 4.1 with Karin kinan and
federo and Bruno guests today we'll be
discussing literature as uncertainty
practice creative encounters with the
world there will be a presentation
followed by some comments and discussion
so thank you all for joining and to you
Ken for the
presentation thank you thank you Daniel
for inviting me um I'm speaking here
from the Norwegian Institute in Rome um
and I'm very much looking forward to the
responses from Bruno and Federico and um
whatever questions may come up uh in the
chat later
on I'm going to talk about predictive
Pro procing in relation to
literature from the one side looking at
ways in
which we can use the framework of
predictive processing in order to make
sense of what literature is and what it
does um but also going the other way
thinking about what elements of
predictive processing literature might
um pose a challenge for or um provide a
very interesting case study to perhaps
provoke further discussion
a lot of what I'm going to say is based
on my book probability designs which
came out with Oxford University bre in
2020 um I'm going to introduce the
concept um I'm going to relate it to the
concept of form which is a concept from
that is much used in literary studies um
I'm going to raise the question of what
makes literature different from other
art forms and I'm going to link that to
a very particular kind of cognitive work
that literally form the long form
written of um a novel enables um and
then in a final move I'm going to talk
about the ways in which literature works
as an uncertainty practice in the world
and what this has to do with um the
general experience of
contingency so let's start with the
probability
designs um and being a literary scholar
I'll start with a textual example this
is from Virginia W's novel
Orlando um which is a novel where the
main character starts as a man in the
Renaissance then suddenly turns into a
woman in the 18th century and Carries On
as a woman until um about the 20th
century at this point in the book we're
still in the Renaissance young Orlando
has decided to become a poet until one
day he looks out of the window and see
he sees the splendid natural Green in
the garden after that
and here I quote Virginia wol of course
he could write no more green in nature
is one thing Green in literature another
nature and lce seem to have a mutual
antipathy bring them together and they
tear each other to Pieces the Shade of
Green Orlando now saw spoiled his rhyme
and split his
meter so what we have here on a very
basic level is of course a prediction
era he wanted to become a poet um he
looks outside of know he sees something
surprising and he changes his plan in
terms of a narrative such prediction
errors would be plot events here
something happens that changes
fundamentally the trajectory um of the
further course of the narrative orando
leaves his desks and his plans of
becoming a writer and what is likely to
happen next in the novel has just
changed these prediction errors are of
course um modulated with Precision with
our sense of how just how good that
information is just how reliable it is
and in litery text that is quite often
tied to the character's
perspective um so it's Orlando who sees
that green is part of his perception um
and it's very often also tied to the
embodied experience of the characters
and the way in which they're positioned
in the fictional World in particular in
the long form of the novel and this has
been discussed in military studies for a
very long time at least since M B's idea
that the novel is a polyphonous genre
genre of many voices you usually have
multiple different perspectives on the
Character level but also on the level of
the narrator who can be more or less
reliable so that's very much um part of
a standard uh setup for the novel to
have these multiple different um
perspectives but it's not just the
spatial position
um that gives um Precision in a literary
text it is also on the level of
temporality so if we take the last um
sentence it has a particular Rhythm um
that changes Midway through the sentence
so the Shade of Green Orlando is I am
then you have the now saw where the
Rhythm sort of changes and that's of
course exactly the moment of the
prediction eror spoils his rhyme and
split his meter the second half of the
sentence moves into traic foot um wolf I
think very consciously um replaces um
the sentence in order to um make that um
prediction error not just
something that we rationalize but really
something that you experience as a
reader um on a quite embodied level so
also the pacing of the pros the pacing
of the language that we read um works as
precision and guides readers
attention um these features that wolf
chooses to modulate Precision here the
different meters um of verse are of
course Very Much tied to the period in
which Orlando is at this point in the
Noel Renaissance poetry um he's in the
Renaissance where poetry is one of the
Dom modes of um literary expression and
that takes me to the third level of the
probability design the Precision
expectations so expectations about where
we likely to find um good um Precision
the kind of parameters um within which
we direct our
attention so um the setting in the
Renaissance the fact that he wres um
poetry um goes together with the choice
um of the me that here and both I think
quite systematically develops that as
she moves through the different periods
so when we're in the Victorian period we
read that sentences swelled adjectives
multiplied lyrics became epics and
little Trifles that have been sentence
essays a sentence long we now
encyclopedias in 10 or 20
volumes um you don't need to have read
Dickens to know that Victorian novels
are long um and wolf actually here even
in Acts she's not just saying that Pros
um has a very long binded format long
binded syntax in Victorian novels she
actually performs that um here as well
again drawing attention to the framework
within which we're moving so in litery
texts quite often um the genre or
historically specific modes of writing
provide Precision expectations for
readers and indicate where it is worth
paying attention to while
reading so the probability design then
brings together all three levels the
level of the plot and the prediction
errors the level of perspective and
pacing and um precision and the level of
different styles of writing different
kinds of intertextual references on the
level of precision
expectations um it's an Artful
configuration of words that provides a
design sensory flow and reshapes readers
generative models for the duration of
reading and then Des sign sensory flow I
think sits between the sort of everyday
setting where of course we have a
sensory flow but it's not um designed
it's not ordered for us and cases of um
for example Dreaming or mind wandering
where we we're moving through the
imagination um as Andy Clark says in
serving uncertainty such systems of
dreaming and mind wandering command
generative model capable of
reconstructing the sensory signal using
knowledge of interacting forces in the
world that process of reconstruction
tuned and deployed in a presence of the
sensory signal paves the way for
processes of outright construction able
to perform able to perform and develop
in the absence of the usual sensory flow
so in the case of reading we have an
absence of the usual sensory flow but
that doesn't have to be reconstructed
completely on the basis
um of what we already have what we
already know instead it is reconstructed
on the basis of this design sensory flow
of the liter text that provides us with
um prediction errors in the first place
but then as I have shown um a whole set
of different elements that also model um
how we inference on the level of
precision and precision
expectation um what I talk about in
terms of probability
designs arguably can also be found in
other kinds of artworks and um for
example in the case of painting the
composition would be a kind of
probability design um and for that case
the work of Co bment um is very
interesting because they talk about the
ways in which the composition of a
painting has the capacity to create
particular aesthetic emotions
um and that is tied to a faster than
predicted rate of prediction error
reduction meaning um that you see a
painting and you're quite startled it's
not easy to make out what it is that
you'll see but then because it is
designed because the painting has a
composition you can actually make sense
of um what you're seeing in front of you
at a much faster rate than you would
predict at a much faster rate than what
you would be able ble to do um in a real
world setting and that creates a
positive aesthetic emotion even if the
painting perhaps depicts um something
that would evoke quite negative emotions
and I think something like that is
certainly also true for literary
probability designs that they have a way
of um making you navigate um that
probability design at a faster than
predicted rate of prediction error
reduction um but I would also say that
there are quite significant differences
between um paintings and literary texts
just because of the way in which um
they're made the way the things of which
they consist in Reading literature um
you usually have an engagement that
extends over much longer periods of time
than looking at a painting when you read
a novel you spent probably about a week
with it reading a couple of chapters
here and a couple of chapters there so
there is a way in which your everyday
life and your reading process are folded
into one another as you go through um
reading that long form um fictional
text um reading a novel also asks you to
engage with visual stimulus but that
visual stimulus is a lot poorer um than
would you have in images it's just black
letters on a white
page so there are um quite important
differences that I think is important uh
to keep in
mind both um literary texts as well as
other art forms can create a feeling of
presence um in readers and that's um
based on work that I've done together
with Federico and colleagues looking at
Presence flow and narrative
absorption where we distinguish between
um motor intentions um that would be you
handling the book and turning the pages
proximal intentions
um where you use language toact or give
sense reactions of a character so you
experience um embodied resonances around
a character's movement for example while
reading that generates um core presence
and then there also discal intentions um
where you use the probability design to
make accurate predictions of what a
character will think or feel so they
develop a kind of strategy for getting
better off predicting um what that
character um will do um and that creates
extended presence so it has a kind of
second track or a meta track um to um
the inferencing process and I think for
the literary probability design that
level of the extended presence is where
most of the really interesting thing
happens and I think that is to do with
the way in which literally form or
probability design can move Beyond myis
can move Beyond just
representing um something that is there
I'll give you an example from a mid 18th
century short story called the noble man
where a young woman is escaping from the
shadow of her ancestors and she does
that by taking the portraits of the
ancestors of the wall and using them as
planks to run across the mold
um around the
shadow Julie jumps lightly on the face
of one of her ancestors as she leaves
the shadow she jumps on one of the
portraits um that face of her ancestors
renss and snaps beneath her
feet um there is of course here a highly
embodied language that invites embodied
residences and readers but at the same
time um that design sensory flow also
goes beyond the remit of real world
sensory motor
contingencies um I mean I'm I'm not sure
it's possible to actually walk across uh
canvas on water and not sink or I'm not
sure how fast you need to run for that
um exercise to work out that however is
usually not a question um that we ask
ourselves when we read that and that is
I think because on the level of the
probability design um all of that hangs
together all of that has its logic um it
is of course was very funny very ironic
that she uses exactly the sort of um the
elements indicating the authority of her
ancestors the portraits um for her
getaway so on the logic of the
probability design um all of that hangs
together all of that makes sense um and
that enables um the litery text even
though it draws very much on embodied
resonances um to move away from um real
world sensory motor contingencies and to
reshape the inferences that are
available to
us moreover um Beyond these non-mimetic
um moments liter texts very often invite
what pulo and colleagues have called
epistemic active inferences that is you
want to make a change in the world in
order to see um what provides better
information and in the case of epistemic
active influences you would do that in
your head you would scrope for
information by
manipulating um the environment mentally
readers I think constantly do that
you're constantly constructing
alternative scenarios along the lines of
oh if she hadn't done that or um that
character really should have come in
time um Etc um you constantly project
alternative outcomes sometimes texts
even give you prompts for that but these
epistemic active differences that
forward scoping while reading um is a
fundamental part of the reading process
and I think it is most prominent or most
noticeable when you read the book again
that you've read several years ago um
because it then quite often turns into a
very different um experience the kind of
sense that you make of it the meaning
that it has for you tends to be very um
different just to give um a banal
example reading anakaren before and
after a divorce I expect would have a
very different kind of um experience
that goes with it and I think that has
to do with the fact that yes we're
reading the same text yes the plot
events do not change um but the small uh
inferencing processes that we run as
readers um these epidemic active
entrances are very much to do with the
online present leing process and their
fundament to the kind of meaning that we
configure out of reading a novel and
that changes of course between um
different iterations of reading the
text a second element um that I think is
quite specific to um a literary
probability design is the way in which
novels allow you to explore inner states
and of course the novel has um
traditionally been considered as the
cultural technology for the exploration
of IM States and I think there is a
predictive processing story um to that
um insight and it is to do with what
Andy Clark in his uh 2013 BBS piece
called the dark room problem um where he
poses the problem of um well if we want
to minimize prediction errors why do we
not um just close the door shut lines
and of the lights um one of the
responses or the possible solutions that
have been put forward for this dark room
Problem by pulo and colleagues is to say
well actually there is an inceptive and
an
exceptive aspect to this we keep our
interception very stable so we don't
want to have um a heart that beats very
F we don't to be out of breath we don't
want our tummies to be upset and if we
keep that stable um um then we can be
very adventurous exploring uh exception
exploring um the outside world um and I
would suggest that in the case of
reading actually the opposite is the
case we keep extra reception very stable
um we don't want to be distracted we um
focus on this very poor stimulus of just
words on the page um keeping whatever
attracts our extra reception um quite
static
and that then in turn allows us to be
quite adventurous when it comes to
exploring our inates the ways in which
we respond to what we've read um very
much of course emotional responses and
in the work of Lisa Felman Garrett
interception has of course been um tied
within a predictive processing framework
to emotional
processes um but I think also things
like um linking that to mind wanding Etc
um would um fall within this exploration
of in the states so the novel as a
cultural technology exactly because it
is um so stable when it comes to the
stimulus allows for an exploration of
interception and inner
STS there's the second aspect to that um
which is perhaps even more speculative
and that is to do with the way in which
which um embodied resonances might um be
affected by the fact that we're reading
that as letters on the page so in the
study by shill and all um they were
interested in the ways in which you can
get around sensory attenuation so the
ways in which you can lift um the
attenuation of the sensory feedback that
what you don't want to have while you're
moving um they use the
of um the escalation of forse so if
someone pushes at you and you asked to
push back to the same degree you will
usually push harder than the pushing um
that comes against you exactly because
you don't have a very good sense of how
hard you're actually
pushing um that kind of um Force
escalation can be apparently um avoid it
if you use a kind of interface that
redirects
um what it is you're touring and
arguably words on the page are a similar
kind of interface so using um an
interface for pushing that redirects our
movement in this case would limit
sensory attenuation you would have a
better sense of what you're actually
doing in an embodied um sense and
perhaps also embodied resonances of
words on the page might have a similar
effect now like I said this is quite
speculative but I think it would be
interesting to see whether there is some
kind of empirical reality to that and it
would go together I think with this idea
that litery texts as an exploration of
inner states allow for more precise
investigation of what's going on within
us um then basic offline thinking would
enable um the elements of
of reflection um can also be tied I
think very much to the way in which
prision is modulated in probability
designs and here I suggest that litery
texts have a way of constantly providing
what I call Meta fictional nudges so
nudges um that provide a meta
perspective on the kind of immersive
experience that you're
having I take the term of the nudge from
John Sutton's work on um Sports
Performance where he talks about
cricketers who use words for self-cueing
um so that they can sculpt the ongoing
flow of motion by saying things like
battle or keep the battle something like
that so you adjust what it is you're
doing in the flow of the action and I
think that's exactly what very often
happens in litery texts I've given one
example here from Francis Buffer's um
the go Golden Hill where we're in the
middle of a Fel Septimus disengaged with
a WRA of Steel and lunch lower in SE
Smith replied in C seek
supreme but this is really useless and
no more enables the reader to see the
battle than if I shout numbers at you
which indeed I appear to be doing so
here you've got exactly that shift from
a quite immersive description to these
French numerals which of course indicate
fencing decis uh fencing positions um
first working as quite integrated quite
subtle metafictional nudges and then
being taken up by the narrator to a
full-blown um meta fictional meta
narrative
reflection and that's something that
happens quite commonly in litery text
and I think invites readers exactly for
that kind of uh shift of
levels also the interconnectivity of
text that I've talked about in terms of
that third order level is something that
I think allows L text to do some quite
particular kind of cognitive work and
here my example is a novel called de
composition angara where the main
character is a serial killer who works
on the basis of PRS In Search of Lost
Time and the rule that he gives himself
is that he takes up a volume of pro um
identifies the characters say
Madame um counts when she appears in a
given part of the book so she would be
character number 37 who appears in that
part of the book then he goes and sits
in the park and counts the passes by
number 37 if it is a woman he will go
after them and kill them and then go
home and uh open an electronic copy of
Prest Noel and remove that character
from it so here we have a case of a very
strong emphasis on um that in textual
Dimension that um Precision expectation
Dimension and that is highlighted even
on the level um of the words that she
uses for example after the description
of the kill rule um the narrator says
deushi with happiness joyfully um you're
going to bed which is a riff on the
first sentence of BR novel where it's
the B Earth so early um I used to go to
um so gar quite systematically uses not
only the character repertoire of post um
but also um the language to establish
that
interconnectivity um and I think that
allows readers to reflect both on the
rules and predictabilities of what's
going on in that novel um but it also
allows them to reflect on where they
actually take their expectations from I
mean is it the crime novel the serial
killer narrative um is it the crime
Society modern uh novel for which Cru um
stands so as you're exploring Deton
Library um this is something you can do
um in the literary text exactly because
it provides scaffolding for it because
it ties it to different characters to
titles of novels to ways of writing um
Etc so that exploration of the mental
library of different kind of precision
expectations or sets of precision
expectations and that is a term I take
from PI the mental Library um is also I
think something quite
particularly suited for litery texts um
because it allows a moment of stability
and it makes
these prediction are U sorry Precision
expectations perceptible um by
highlighting them and making them part
of the story
itself so to summarize briefly um what I
think is quite particular about
literally probability designs is the
huge space they give to epistemic active
inferences um it's the enabling of the
exploration of inner states and I think
that is in particular linked to this
long form written text where you keep
coming back um to the same fictional
World while your everyday life um is
going
on um and thirdly that it allows you to
attend to Precision expectations this
third order level um of cognition which
in an everyday setting in the ongoing
flow of action um you cannot really
attend to quite as easily so the long
form written probability design of the
novel um enables you to do all of that
cognitive work um to an extent which is
hardly
imagin hardly imaginable in an everyday
context um I think all of that is tied
to form and probability designs um very
much corresponds to a general notion of
form and I take my understanding of form
from fed Schiller's book on the
aesthetic education of mankind he sees
form as a means to provide freedom for
the human mind and here of course the
epistemic act of entrances this roaming
of the mind um is one um element that's
quite important but that I think is made
possible by the scaffolding provided in
the litery text exactly through that
design sensory flow that keeps um these
movements um discernable and thinkable
that understanding of form as a space of
Freedom as a space where you can watch
yourself think um is quite different
from how form is generally understood um
certainly in literary studies Caroline
lavine's recent book um forms which has
um been very influential in literary
studies says well there are social forms
and there are also aesthetic forms so
social forms for example would be the
layout of a classroom and the aesthetic
form of the novel um can pick that up
and integrate it for example in a novel
like um J A where we have a classroom
setting um and she makes a very
interesting argument I think about the
common durability between aesthetic and
social forms but she also insists that
forms as designed arrangements are
deliberately crafted to impose order
just like art objects um and I think is
perhaps a little further than I'm
willing to go because certainly
probability designs provide patterns
they provide scaffoldings um for us to
give structure um to the experience of
reading but I don't think they very
strictly speaking impose
order um for LaVine um the only way in
which literally forms can create
contingency can create a sense of that
things things don't necessarily are the
way um in which they appear to us now
that there's always an
alternative that um happens when you
have different kinds of form collided
but form in and of itself wouldn't give
space to that kind of contingency
exactly because it imposes
order and I think the probability design
idea allows you to rethink um the role
of
contingency in
um litery forms uh and I've explored
that in particular in my most recent
project where I look at how authors
create um probability designs how they
write their novels um and there I
suggest that contingency not only plays
an enormous role in the creative process
itself but it is actually inbuilt in
literally form that also deploy form um
to integrate contingency into that text
to always face um for alternative ways
of interpreting things making that
available to readers so form of course
encompasses contingency it is a
contingency trap as I suggest but it's
the kind of trap that you see at the
bottom where the mouth will be caught um
but it can still run around and it gets
stabilized enough for you to observe the
kind of things it's actually doing um
form is not the kind of contingency trap
that you can see at the top that just
kills the mouse
dead to give you an example of what one
of these contingency traps um looks like
um I'll briefly talk about italino
castle of Ross
Destinies where in the very process of
narration you have this very alator um
chance-based composition process where
terot cards are placed on the table and
the narrators develop their narrative
from the card that they happen to draw
and place on the table so on the level
of narration we have a representation of
contingency but much more interesting it
also thematizes the way in which
contingency is inbuilt in the form
itself because in the first iteration of
that narrative technique the Middle
Point the middle spot of the
tarot um cards remains empty and um this
is work by Natalie burkeman um who
suggests that this is a case of the
cleam men um the swerve or deviation
from a planned
protocol um the swerve or Camen in terms
of a probability design would be an
underspecified element um that provokes
further inferencing because the middle
spot in um this ter tarot tapestry is
kept empty you can always generate um
new stories out of it and similarly
litery texts always need to have some
kind of flaw something that doesn't add
quite up in order to um provide exactly
the space um to explore contingency
while reading so I think in the very
design of a probability design um there
are very often these moments of a break
or a flaw that enable these Freer um
formal patterns of inferencing and
meaning
making with that in mind I want to come
to the last part of my talk where I
address the issue of how literature
works as an uncertainty practice uh in
the real
world um and here I draw on an article
that I published last year where I also
draw on the piece by Miller and
colleagues um where they talk about the
value of uncertainty in the context of
algorithm
um and the way in which algorithms um
make volatile environments more
manageable um they talk about
personalization algorithms so like when
you order a book and you get five
recommendations on the basis of what
you've ordered before these kinds of
mechanisms that make the world more
predictable more um according to how
you've behaved in the past but they also
have a very interesting example of
someone who programs an app for his
phone um that randomizes his food
deliveries so he never knows um what he
gets so you can use these Technologies
to go in both
directions um and make sense of um the
volatile environments that we live in
they briefly touch on literature in that
article and they say that it's a safe
space or a safe kind of environment
for
exploration which in a way I think goes
together with a lot of things that have
been said about literature in a sort of
larger um context where this is a space
where your actions wouldn't have
consequences where the killer from um
gar novel doesn't come out of the novel
to get you but of course you can also
not save any of the characters in the
novel so it is a space um of its own
where you don't um need to fear
consequences of actions so in that sense
of course it is safe um but I think it
is a lot more than just a curated space
for Thought
experiments um I think it is a lot more
than that exactly because of the ways in
which reading a literary text has a way
of tying itself um into your everyday
experience as you do that over multiple
weeks because of the ways in which it
draws attention to your reactions um to
what you're reading so for example
inos Madame or the person identified as
Madame by the killer actually gets away
and that goes very much against um what
the whole novel was set up to do um and
I think at that point you would perhaps
ask yourself why perhaps you Shar the
disappointment of the killer then you
might ask yourself why you do that um or
you don't do that and then you're
wondering where the novel is going to go
um so the way in which the liter text um
is set up making things uncertain um or
contingent is often also an invitation
to reflect on how you react to that um
yourself both with the exploration of
inate but also in tandem with that
metafictional nudges that I was talking
about earlier
on and I think that even applies for the
question of um Precision expectations
where the way in which this is set up in
G to stay with that example from the
moment that Madame Loop gets away we've
got continually new iterations of
different character kills in different
narrative modes um there even is an
evocation of an ego shooter um where the
killer based basically depopulates the
entire world of In Search of Lost times
uh In Search of Lost time and that
variation of narrative speed um I think
is a way of drawing attention to um the
different regimes of attention that we
go through in that novel The ego shoter
going very fast very quickly and of
course proves Noel because of the way in
which he writes and how long the thing
is um which grows very slowly so that
would allow for example for reflecting
on um the different kind of
accelerations or attention regimes um
that we operate in while reading that
Noel the herself actually in an
interview draws attention to the way in
which the experience of reading a book
is by no means a safe environment she
says it reorders the circulation of your
affects it manipulates your desires your
perceptions your efforts in ways that
are not predictable
so literature to conclude my
presentation and its probability designs
are actually quite strange think about
Julie running across the portraits of
her ancestors and not exactly safe
because theyve constantly forced you um
to reflect on what's going on to reflect
on how you think about yourself they
have the potential to at least while the
reading process is going on to reshape
the generative model with this design
sense Reflow and they make elements of
cognition that are usually invisible
available to
reflection so they enable creative
contingent ways to rethink yourself and
the world and I think that's as much as
we can ask of any kind of cultural
technology thank
you thank you very much Karen was really
fascinating account of um how literature
can be seen through the lens of of
predictive processing and an active
inference and I think I would like to um
because you dived really directly into
how to do this how to use this framework
to to think about literature and how
readers engage with the literature but
maybe other question that can be
interesting for for a broader audience
and this is a um so what do you think
that this perspective is offering um
that is new or that is more effective in
terms of um how we can better explain
what's going on in literature and when
we engage with literature in comparison
to um existing Frameworks or alternative
uh theories that deal with the with
similar um aspects of
literature um that is an enormous
question
um I think one of the reasons why I've
decided to spend quite a lot of time
with protective processing um to think
about literature is that it allows you
to look at multiple levels together so
it allows you to think about the plot
but also how that's connected to the
character and how they move through the
fictional world and then you can also
make links to um yeah very particular
kind of genre protocols for for example
or intertextual links um so I think
because of the the way in which it works
across different levels um and still the
flexibility that I see um in the model
um what I like about it in terms of
thinking about literation why I think is
effective is that it actually allows you
to think things together that
traditionally in liter studies we don't
think together so character and plot um
are usually two different
strs of things that you're looking
at yeah great answer and actually made
me think about
[Music]
another maybe issue that it's uh very
often uh debated or maybe not enough
debated sometimes in in literary
theories and is about the need or the
possibility actually to have a
comprehensive and Universal theory of of
narrative of fiction of literature and
by what what you've said and also this
is my impression um in other Reflections
that well it seems like that something
like um thetive processing framework and
active difference similar to how they've
been proposed in the cognitive Sciences
can aim at being this um overarching
theory for describing and explaining
different aspects of narrative and so my
question is do you think this desirable
and it's possible and how this can be um
can go together uh with the need uh that
has been expressed multiple times in the
humanities of having different
perspectives and different
um people with different theories that
can actually bring us to a deeper
knowledge of a
phenomenon
um again a very big question um
I
think with predictive processing you can
ask very different questions of a text
um and you're
not tied to so if we're thinking about
universals um that very often comes with
a category or a set of categories so I
don't know four different character
types and then you've got everything in
compass um so it very often comes with a
top
down um imposition of boxes so you've
got the hero and the helper and just to
take a very basic example of Pop's fairy
tale studies the
structuralist
morphology um what I like about
predictive processing is that you can do
that bottom up um you don't have to look
for a particular character category in a
text
um so you can with that account
for um any number of narratives
without um presupposing heart
distinctions between types or structural
boundaries instead you can trace how the
text or the novel itself establishes um
those categories or keeps them open I
mean that I think that is a lot more
common in in literary novels that the
and um the hero um are not very easily
to be
distinguished um so I think one of the
attractions is this bottom up element to
break processing well that it allows you
to do bottom up analysis that can all be
analyzed with the same analytical
vocabulary yeah thank you yeah I like
the the the perspective and I'd like to
to ask you last question before uh
letting the the floor to to Bruno and I
know that you in your work um and it's
an example of how you uh presented this
today you look at text from different
epochs right not just contemporary
material like to look at how this Theory
can work with the with text from from
the past so I always wondering how um
this can work well uh
this way of of looking at the text and
thinking about probability so kind of
cognitive process that readers are doing
or um hypothetical readers are doing and
how do you in your experience in your
analysis of the of several literary
works that you've done how well do you
think this is applicable to text from
the past and uh or where do you see the
limitations
are um so I think it is
very well applicable um in fact I got
into predictive processing because one
of the central categories of early
modern literary theory is
probability um and I was working
on 17th 18th century literature looking
at ways in which how they thought about
what was happening when people read how
that corresponds to current strands in
cognitive science our philosophy of mind
so um for probability I actually started
um from the early modern period where it
was very important that the text was
probable um and went from there to see
well actually predictive processing as a
theoretical model Works quite well to
understand how these um probability
calul
calculus um actually work so
interestingly enough i i p the other way
around
um and certainly in the early modern
period the way you thought about um many
literary works not all of them was you
know um not is it true or is it false
but is it probable is it well enough
designed does it have a good enough plot
to hold together so that you believe it
whether it's true or not um so I think
predictive
processing works very well
um for I I mean one would have of course
to put it to the test and one would have
to apply it to Medieval texts or ancient
texts as well um but certainly for the
periods that I know which is mostly the
early modern um period it it works quite
well um it would be interesting to see
what would be the the sort of limit
cases where um the idea that you've got
an ongoing um calculus that the
trajectory of the narrative is Con
updated um whether it wouldn't work I
think that would be very interesting to
see what kind of narrative that
was thank
you okay so I guess I'll just move on
thank you uh for that lovely
presentation and and for sharing your
book it's been quite an interesting read
and there really um changed a few things
how I think a few things in my field
um I just want to say that I come from a
very different field um anthropology and
archaeology but I think that a lot of
what you say actually there's some
parallels between the work that we've
been doing um just to
specify uh that worked mostly with the
breakage of form and I I'll ask a few
questions about this
um uh
particularly uh in terms of craft work
so a lot of work I do is on Craft work
and there's an interesting point you
rais in in in the book about and and
also in your presentation about how
reading what what makes literature so
exceptional in a sense what makes it
different and I'm wondering if you find
any parallels between which of the
processes of probability design with uh
with craft work with actual work with
with materials um yeah I'll start with
that
um so so you're thinking of the actual
Act of
making a pot for um yeah sure
yeah um I think there
are similarities certainly I think I I I
have I have to admit I have no idea how
you make a pop no worries um but I I
assume it is also a more long form
engagement it's something that unfolds
in the flow of time and um where the
material that you're working with gives
you different kinds of resistance um and
you have different strategies of of
working with it or working around that
resistance so I think in in that way
it's probably similar to the reading
process that it is something that
unfolds over time and where you get a
sense of what is likely you know going
to work um what kind of approach you're
like
to yeah it's is likely
going to help you make sense of what it
is that you're reading um so I think in
that sense um there are a lot of
similarities there um I think one of the
differences is of course that reading
requires you to work with
language whereas the material um of the
pot
is not strictly speaking symbolic um I'm
very happy to talk about the symbolism
of a material form
um but it's not uh first and foremost
first and foremost it's matter that you
shave um so I think there is a
difference with um how you handle and
manipulate that in your head um from
what you do as a
reader yeah I'm glad that you say that
it's been something been debated a lot
in our fields in terms of there's a turn
around trying to make a looking at
materials as as as if you were reading a
text a lot of complication arose which
you just synthesized very well I think
but um I think I'll I'll shift to the
the next Point really is is in terms of
form I'm quite interesting this point
because you seem to suggest that form is
something
emergent which I think is partly fueled
by this U by the active inference
framework
um and if I understood correctly would
be one would be in this sense um uh the
design sensory flow yeah um and there's
this tendency we have of trying to kind
of petrify it maintain it make it
durable um and uh but at the same time
we're facing challenges right in the
text from when so I would be interested
in looking at if if there is form in the
sense what would be the breakage of the
form so what what would be something
that challenges the form when when when
when is reading or in terms of
probability
design um I think there are multiple
ways in which you can do that
um but before I start talking about that
I I think I mean I would be interested
in actually hearing your take on that
because it it seems to me again as
someone who's not very well informed
when it comes to craft that if you do
have a material object I mean you speak
about fossil
and I mean these are stable
configurations M
um that of course you can't perceive the
whole pot at a time but you can get an
outline of it so if you or if you look
at the painting you know you can do a
composition sketch um that puts together
all the dominant lines and the outlines
um so that you can see where the
triangles are on the center of gravity
or um the the the vanishing point Etc so
it seems to me that in the case of
visual art and and also material objects
there is a way in which the form is much
more immediately
perceptible whereas um in a literary
text and especially in a long form text
like the Noel
um it's really only something
that yeah it's it's somewhere there in
the text but I think as soon as as you
try to draw a diagram uh as soon as you
try to you know do these plot lines or
whatever people have
attempted um it sort of doesn't quite
capture
it I think you do have an intuitive
sense of um what kind of shape the whole
thing has and I think there are various
strategies when you start a Noel um of
projecting what kind of ending it's
likely going to have um evoking General
protocols for example is establishing a
setting that will come up again at the
end Etc so there ways of signaling
formal coherence in a text um but I
would be hardpressed to imagine how that
would have the same kind
of perceptual Unity I think that I'm
looking at AAS for example
has um still I spoke of course about um
cracks and flaw
in um the probability
design um and I think those are um
exactly these moments that are heavily
um
underdetermined um that like the the
character getting away in in the Cru
killer novel when everything has been
set up to say well this is not going to
happen this is completely impossible and
it it's also never explained properly um
one example that immediately I think
comes to mind or another example would
be sort of what happens between
chapters when characters at the end of
the chapter Clos the door and then the
new morning starts the next chapter and
you you sort of know what happened in
the night but it's not made explicit so
I think there are various points um in
the narrative or in the novel um where
you can position those cracks and and
those flaws um and I think some of them
are to do with the very material layout
like chapter endings um but mostly I
think it will be on the level of how the
narrative is
constructed does that answer your
question yeah I think it's it's true is
it must more of a it's much more fluid
this idea of of of of form really so
it's hard to
disentangle the this what would be the
exact let's say not the exact opposite
but more or less the case about how how
form is really
dissolved if to phrase it that way um I
think there's a point I I want to ask
you about um in terms of because you
mentioned like uh plot events or these
things that that did not happen a lot in
and maybe I'm referring to exclusively
on on your book in that case all about
the this narrated and um and I'm Wonder
wondering you you raised a really
interesting quote that
um I think I have it written here I can
say directly yeah the unfulfilled
possibilities or to put it more
dramatically the hypothesis that die
with each transformation in a plot event
stay with the probability design and I
actually think this is quite a crucial
remark in that sense to understand how
these let's say interruptions that are
flowing through the the text actually
come to shape the the this form as you
as you're describing um so my question
is are they would it be is there a
selective process into how some
hypothesis might die out why others stay
with the POs sorry probity design is
that um maybe so bit confusing the
question but um I think I understand it
um so I think that is very much to do
with the individual reader um and
how you move through the text so if we
think of a hypothesis that
dies um I don't know that an now St with
a husband you know which is possible at
multiple points in the book um it is a
very dead um hypothesis though but of
course you could read the novel and at
every point you know imagine how you
know her life could have been different
it may even have been better um I think
that depends on your take on
Roni um but I think it is very much to
do with um exactly the kind of epistemic
active inferences that become dominant
across the reading process and it's very
much to do I think also with the kind of
emotional investment that might have as
a reader because you feel sympathy with
a particular character or because you
think oh this character is a lot more
interesting than I actually thought um
often when you read a novel The Second
Time Around and you start noticing the
things that you haven't noticed um the
first time
around um so I
think I don't think there is um I don't
think it's predictable I think that is
exactly which of these hypothesis
that stay with the probability design
even though they don't get realized I
think that very much depends on what
happens um during the reading process
what for whatever reason is attractive
for a reader to carry with him or her
through the
text okay I see your point um in terms
of this rereading I think maybe I'm
passing too much time so I'll leave this
as the last question before now um in
terms of the rereading uh process um and
these ideas that these processes that
are adding uncertainty let's say to the
to the narrative um
so would would that be reconfigured in
terms of these these hypothesis with the
rereading
um are some of these taken or are they
some of them just left to die
eventually because of this constant
reevaluation or reiteration of of the of
of looking through the text and for the
reader I mean
yeah yeah I think most of the you know
possible Alternatives will never cross
your mind um because there are just too
many of them um so I think the the one
if you do carry an alternative
hypothesis with you um it will be one
that for one reason or another you have
an emotional investment and all you find
particularly interesting at given point
um so I think it it
leaves potentially an infinite range of
making epistemic active influences but
you won't have the time or the interest
or the energy to make all of them um I
think it will be a very few of
those okay see Point um yeah sorry I
said it was the last one so I'll keep my
promise yeah maybe I can add one small
things it's a comment on your previous
question and to C answer because we
touched upon this in the article me and
K have written together and then you
mentioned today this distinction between
core presence and um extensive presence
right so the difference between the
proximal intention and the distant
intention so you can make predictions
and and then accept the errors coming
through out of them as long as they
don't disrupt too much the the goal that
you have the the the distant intentions
that you have and they are driven by
situational factors of by Jean
convention let's say that you're reading
a detective novel if you keep making
predictions about who the murderer is
and the murder gets revealed on page
three that would be a to an abrupt
disruption for you to accept that and
then wanting to keep engaging with that
kind of narrative and and and
so you you ask if there's a trade-off or
some uh things that um are not included
in the probability design or get
discarded in the writing process because
they're not they don't work well in the
overall design so maybe this is an
example of something that could in some
cases if you're really not if you're
writing something that is subverting the
Jean convention and not really um
putting the emphasis on who's the um the
murder but wanting to play with the the
Gen of the detective story but this this
could work but in most cases for most
readers that want a detective novel um
that wouldn't
work I see um that's is quite
interesting because uh what I see is all
these what I find interesting because
for us when we're working with craft
work on certainty seems to be of the
external world you know it comes in it
everything's messy um the things Decay
they wither they break down so you need
to adjust whereas here find it
interesting because a lot of this uh
uncertainty comes from the actual design
of the of the of the of the text as as
as it's been uh described and so in that
sense
um is there an element to this to this
design in the writing that one
can one can try to see these these um
let's say these hypotheses that uh that
were never written
do you find traces of these in the
design for
example when when when the text is
designed do you find traces of these
doubts let's say of the of the
writer when when they were do you know
what I
mean something that might be external to
something
that was intended but is can can one
highlight these in the text about about
uh the moments of doubt the author has
when they're writing it the reason why
I'm saying that is that is there
uncertainty that is created
inadvertently when it's when the text is
being written that's that's my point I
don't know if
it's yeah I think um that certainly
happens because I mean I talked about
how reading is a long-term process but
of course writing a novel is an even
longer
process um where if you look in into
manuscripts you can see authors you know
changing their minds um and that will
leave traces um as they keep copying and
editing um what they've written um and
again with a text that is as large as a
novel is I mean all of these are of
course meticulously edited but I think
there is space for you know the mess as
you call it um to come in from the
different manuscript um
stages um sometimes that even continues
after publication um one of the early
modern authors I've worked on Samuel
Richardson um he wrote a novel called
Clarissa where one of the protagonists
is an aristocrat and he thought he had
written him in a very unattractive way
and nobody would like him and of course
all the readers or many readers thought
you know he was the real hero of this
piece
um so there must have something gotten
in there um that he didn't so it's not a
question of um you have an intention and
then you write that there's always stuff
that gets in there I don't know drawing
on cultural Protocols of Rish
Aristocrats that have attraction um
without meaning um to do so and then of
course I mean Richardson then spend you
know various additions trying to edit
out those elements that he didn't want
in there in the first place so I think
that that is a very common um phenomenon
actually that you've got um a lot of
mess um even in in a very well designed
probability
design okay see I can relate to
that it's it's a very interesting
question if I have time to also add the
small thing Daniel is it fine yeah no
because
well some may even argue that so the
uncertainty but not in the sense of of
the mess right of the but in the sense
already of of how uncertainty is defined
by productive processing might be
um the core uh quality of uh of
literature that lasts long and actually
so Ken presented the work BYO calino and
he has written an essay um um I think
the name was is what is a classic and
and his definition of what is a classic
is precisely this text that have
something which is left open so a level
of uncertainty and it can pertain to
many of the different aspects that the
carent touched upon that is is uncertain
because of the overall design of of the
text and and how it works and it's open
also for future generations and that's
why it becomes a classic right because
this uncertainty gets transmitted and
and the text gets transmitted because of
this um leing uncertainty that appeals
to to readers also of the future that
that calino couldn't uh think of or any
any author of Classics couldn't think
of it's quite quite fascinating because
something that stems to mind this
is how
would these different scenarios of
uncertainty I mentioned uh something
that you Ken used a an example in her
book about these things that do not
happen really so
how how would those be scaffolded in the
text you are they is that um for the
reader to be able to follow through on
these
details does it make
sense are you saying it it should be
there there should be textual signals
that you can point to yeah yeah so how
would it be okay I'll give you an
example maybe I'm thinking too much
about
craft so what we see normally is that
when when we set out to learn about
let's say you mentioned Potter so I'll
throw in
Potter um set out to make a part and the
last thing in your mind you know that
you encounter problems the most thing
most of the things you want to learn
about is the techniques to make the
object right but the last thing in your
mind is what will all the that what you
will effectively learn eventually are
actually all the faults that will come
out throughout the whole process right
but you don't intend on learning this
and it's not explicitly taught many of
the cases okay so a lot of this
uncertainty comes from the exposure to
these contingent situations yeah um and
the problem here is because it's not
explicitly
taught there are ways in which
regardless if it's not explicitly taught
what I mean is there are ways in which
somehow
it's there's a sort of scaffolded
learning in the process of something
that's not explicitly stated and I'm
wondering so for example you would say
the first thing you learn when the fault
appears is um is affecting what is the
fault you know what what consequences
would this have you know then the next
stage you learn okay um what do you do
in this situation and then at the last
stage you would say you learn to
anticipate it right so you learn to
anticipate this uncertainty yeah and so
I'm wondering if it's a similar and
maybe I'm thinking too much about craft
but I'm wondering is a similar process
with learning all these
um let's say situations where
uncertainty is being fed into the
narrative to to us to uh get the reader
engaged let's say with the with the
story so does that make sense a little
bit better
maybe I think it does though I'm
beginning to wonder whether that might
not be a point where craft is actually
quite different from Reading because I
think in the craft you want your
strategy to
anticipate um those flaws in in order to
not have them have
whereas I think when you're reading a
literary text you actually do
want that kind of opening um you want to
be
given that kind of Freedom um so I think
you have a similar process of developing
exactly that
um the capacity to anticipate you know
if if the Killer is revealed on page
three um if it's a standard crime novel
um you don't expect much more but you
also know that if someone I don't know
like go chrisy does that so maybe there
is then something else coming that Pro
provides a new way of integrating that
information in a probability design that
is interesting in a different way
because you know who the Killer is but
maybe there's a new question that you
hadn't even thought about
um so I think there is similar
development of let's call it expertise
um as you work with the material in that
case of reading a book um but I think
you
don't this anticipation is not to
prevent um the floor from coming about
it's we need to see okay so now I
anticipate the floor and I want to see
what it yields I want to see um what the
consequences are so I think there is a
difference there um and it may be to
do yeah I'm not entirely sure um what
element that would be um based on but
perhaps it is to do with um letters
being I mean they they don't need the
kind of structural Integrity that a pot
needs to hold together so maybe there is
something on the very materiality of
what we're working with that allows
for um that kind
of
looseness MH I get your
point that's certainly true yeah sorry
yeah
towards a a pause in the chapter a
chapter break here thank you all for the
work I think it the the book and the
other writings have opened up many
avenues for people to explore and I'll
ask one question which is
art has always been
cognitive how though has this cognitive
turn in explicitly exploring the
generation recognition and
interpretation and Analysis of art how
is that explicitly cognitive turn
re-entering into art
itself um that is a very good question
um I don't actually know um I mean there
are obviously writers who have a great
interest in various kinds of cognitive
theories um so who read that because
they're also very self-reflective and
interested in you know how this works
and so arguably there are writers that
take up
um cognitive science Neuroscience um Etc
I'm not familiar with anyone who's taken
up predictive processing though i' be of
course very interested in that um so if
you're talking specifically about the
the sort of creation then I think it
depends very much on what writer
read does that answer your question
yeah it's uh I mean it's an opening to
see how this all happens but like the
craft maker was already doing what they
were
doing what does an explicitly cognitive
lens and a unifying cognitive scientific
approach to memory anticipation the
layers of probability designs that you
articulate how does explicit knowledge
of these in contrast with an implicit
tacit
craft Artisan approach to generating I
mean
icting is still in play even if we were
to take that into a sort of forensic
literary cognitive
science approach so certain things are
in common and yet
now increasingly aspects of the
cognitive
elements maybe in the future people are
reading with
augmentation and there's new
accessory possibilities for
interoception while you're
reading or there's generated
texts not just recommended or Word of
Mouth
dissemination but instantaneous
generation of
designed probability design
the these are these
are shaping the structure of the form in
the
media yeah I think what you rais about
the implicit and the explicit is very
interesting because on the one hand of
course it is an implicit process I mean
you you go and you do it um on the other
hand I do think that the this meta
dimension that I highlighted with the
nudges um it's quite important
especially for the case of literature
that there is a constant element of um
adjusting taking a second order
perspective um so you could very well
use um say an analysis of a Noel
appropriative processing where you
actually identify and tag the
elements um in order to think about what
it is that you've been either reading or
writing so I can see very well that um
that kind of analytical language can
provide um nudges or metap fictional
nudges um for readers or
writers
um
so I think there is a place to think
about predictive processing not only in
terms of the theory that may explain um
what is going on and how how it hangs
together but that could be used
practically um as
well perhaps the panelist and then Karin
any closing thoughts or how you take
this
forward perhaps Bruno then Federico if
you have any
comments well I think um I'll be
brief but uh I think there's lot of for
me personally is got me thinking a lot
about
um how
exactly the sequences of events are
structured in in my line of work and uh
how to look at these things a little bit
more fluidly um with all these
interruptions maybe I think we tend to
be a little bit more schematized with
with with the way we engage with
materials and so I think this is a way
of actually understanding the process as
as it's as it's unfolding really
um and
uh yes I think the the second part has
to do a lot with this idea of
uncertainty and and contingencies which
are seldom used in in in our field so I
think it's
been really inight in that in that
regards to look at um how this is
actually an inbuilt part of the design
process and and uh people come with very
different ways in so as to how to
respond to these different um elements
yeah
sorry that's very very interesting
perspective in see how um looking at
archaeology and crafts can can have
commonalities with the with
and I I
think um what I would like to see done
more and also this what we've been doing
when when writing this article together
and thinking about okay this
is it works with with narrative and and
literature but then can we use this
framework to see also what is specific
about literature as as a text in
comparison to to other media right
because we live now in a society and in
an era where literature liter text are
not the primary medium through which
people experience fictional words and
narrative so this I think because of how
it can work well across different
mediated experiences I think the active
INF framework can be a very um good way
to define what is specific to certain
medium or a certain genre even if you
want as a the specific type of using a
medium in in a certain way um in
comparison to how can tell stories uh
through a different media so I think
yeah I think this would the the the line
I would like to the line of research I
would like to read more
about thank you I think it's really
interesting how we're coming back to the
question of the medium um which has been
so much discussed for media that are not
literature um which has been discussed
for film and virtual reality Video Games
Etc but not as much for literature the
fact that this is a written text that we
spend so yeah this much time with um
which is it has an effect on it and
which is different from the craft
example that um Bruno brought um so I
think from from our discussion now that
is something I want to think more about
um the the the fact that this is a
medium in and of itself and that exactly
specificity that filo highlighted is
very much rooted in
that
meeting cool the kinds of things that
happen on the live stream
medium thank you though all this is
very awesome I hope people enjoy it too
so till next
time thank you very much thank you
e
e e